who's making this lobby come on oh hobby
name will be uh booty now you know what
i'm just gonna call it step pro
password
stuck oh and huawei's setting that up
for those of you watching this hello by
the way oh yeah that's right they can
see this part yeah if you didn't know
the developers of this game
were i mean are however you want to say
based in ukraine and uh actually just
saw an update that they managed to move
all their stuff
out of ukraine which if you weren't
aware there's still a war going on so uh
support these developers because i had
no idea about that and i can't imagine
what they went through to continue
working on this game it's kind of crazy
to think about uh what character you
guys be in i'm jessica i'm william
rick looks kind of like how i feel i
would be kind of like a grizzly idiot so
i'm gonna go with rick oh no he looks
kind of badass too i guess there's
something about the beard at first i
thought he was kind of silly but now he
looks kind of tough
i need someone who looks like an idiot i
need where's me yet it's fine you gotta
you gotta relate to your character if
you're gonna play yeah really if i'm
gonna get into this uh bigfoot rp i
really need to get in bigfoot
yeah this is an rp server right are we
going to help me connect to that i'm
stuck
[Laughter]
you guys ready yeah
welcome back to bigfoot everybody wait
why did i unready ready don't you ever
unread me again wait so we're all ready
how does this start then i click begin
wait i was ready it just says not ready
to click we're beginning are you okay
man
you all right
it always feels like you're you're like
kind of on the verge of like a break or
something
recent reports show the three popular
influencers
the distractible crew video blogger
daniel and his model girlfriend alexa
and their photographer friend ethan oh
no
no
ethan
oh no
fans of the famous couple have been
arranging millions of online broadcasts
asking for help none of them actually
went to the park
ethan just had to do this show didn't he
isn't that what would happen though yeah
you know i think something tragic would
happen and everyone would be like do
streams don't go over there though
i'm not i can't oh wait i think this
game's capturing it like a butthole
frame rate i need to i might need to
adjust some settings here let me just
make sure wait a minute you
plebians and your non-dual pc setups i
know you're silly why am i already on
fire
why are you literally walked through the
fire oh why did we spawn around a fire
all right i got my brother
bigfoot yeah yeah murderer
gentlemen don't forget your tablets that
we left out here under this tent oh no
ethan drake he's gone
why does the gps sensor look like a
harpoon
why are you looking
because i'm bald maybe it just looks
like a harpoon to you
maybe you're just not a smart enough guy
you need to figure it out dubs on the
entire series called drunk minecraft and
none of us know how drunk people
oh [ __ ] we can stab him with a gps
harpoon who wants to have the digital
honor on that that's why they look like
harper hey i solved your mystery win
aren't they supposed to be gun
can i have guns i literally said i have
dib on gun yeah look yeah there's like a
pistol and a rifle and like a shotgun
there was a pistol i have a pistol
i grabbed the gps sensor good job man
good good good you're going to stab
bigger you know how to pull it out i
don't know what it's bound to but i've
got it so this is like a big valley
situation with some sperm rivers uh
which sperm do we want to visit first i
don't know man you lead whoa
moose
[Music]
why it's a moose
that's not why we're whoa i just vaulted
over the fence real cool that's not why
we're here i kill the moose are you
gonna butcher it you know it baby
delicious meats
you just cut one tiny little slice off
of it and it okay and then i just cut my
wrist i think here uh how do we find hi
oh okay thanks i gave marco flair i gave
you my meat
thanks why
thanks
because i had the option to give i was
listening you're just like
you focus on the harpooning aspect hey
what happened to my knife
who did i just hit not me did i hit you
buddy no i swung this sensor and hit
mark and it made a slashing noise oh
well i swung my knife but i saw my knife
over here
i didn't
i'm gonna censor it
don't censor it no no no don't don't
waste that
we need that i assume all right oh we
have at least one
well i thought how
how do we find the bigfoot
where does he live a lot of noise maybe
he'll find us yeah i think we should go
north all right boss hey look there's a
camera floating in the air here oh it's
because it's a scratchy scratchy yeah
take a picture uh
i don't does anyone have the photo
camera i didn't pick it up
when i did not i didn't see it where is
it i'll go grab it yeah go get that go
do your lifeless arm jog and get it for
us would you yeah yeah i want it do you
know where it was he's in the inside on
the table in the camper yeah all right
i'll have night vision no it's night
vision is night vision camera the right
one no phone camera hey guys it was
right on the main kitchen table in a
very table in the camper yeah
well i'm glad that worked out yeah me
too all right don't worry i'm here no
i'm not here yet but i'm almost here
okay
yeah do we need to put you down or
something you're right probably are you
turning this is your secret zombie
situation or is it like a a where take a
goddamn picture and let's get out of
here yes
once i figure out how to pull that out
i'm gonna pop down a camera in there all
right whoa we got one of four photos of
bigfoot's karachi's on trees um
also yeah was that a good sound that
happened that was a good sound right
yeah good sound
all right northward northward there's a
camp when it says bears on bears on cars
in this area
wow well apparently we brought a night
vision camera with no batteries in it so
we can't even use it so
well there's probably just batteries
that would fit in that camera laying
around through the snow quieter sorry so
loud i can't hear you over all the snow
sounds
here mark you have all of our a gun so
have all of our bullet okay thank you i
have a gun why don't you listen to me i
don't think that one guys
what was that sound
uh us yelling at each other no there was
like it sounded like some wood chopping
oh maybe that's like a wicked cabin
let's go fight lexie and i just turned
down the game volume so don't freak out
we're at average foot damn how you just
gonna come at him like that yeah i'm
trying to lure him out i figure he's
probably real sensitive about it you
know what they say about guys with
average
oh
feet
jesus christ
do they say wolf about guys
i'm all out of ideas where do we find
him now i found it his cabin it's right
here we found it
i found bigfoot it's gotta be the one he
just built we heard the chopping i did
hear chomping you know he's right about
that
man this is a refined this is some
refined construction work
if you guys are big fans of santa don't
come in here
why what does that mean
well look look what he he mounted one of
santa's reindeer on this wall what where
this is probably like uh blitzer or
coffee i have no idea
oh
uh his name seems to be
his
reindeer
oh celebrity reindeer the reindeers on
snowboards i agreed to everything at the
entrance 5 p.m ethan ethan ethan wrote
this note
ethan
hey guys look at
that who who just
stole a can of gasoline and a pickaxe
guys it's a picture of weasel from
suicide squad it is a picture of weasel
from suicide squad
that's copyright hey there's something
to take a picture of outside do you guys
see that camera symbol
in the distance there oh yeah i do all
right i'll go find the photo op
wait you were so hot on a gun wait come
here uh literally photo no litter
but
whoa what's up literally hey gun
you were standing next to this for a
while i looked a gun for me uh yeah i
i'm really good at paying attention to
my surroundings we've noticed good job
buddy
well who needs a gun when you have gps
sensor spear that's why they call you
the noticer
uh i picked up an axe a pickaxe and
gasoline so if you guys need that [ __ ]
and i die it seems a little excessive to
have an axe and a pickaxe
yeah but he deserves it what do you want
like a picture with the sign you're
gonna question the noticer are you
really gonna question the notification
notice sir don't you oh i say we go
east oh probably not like this
yeah okay group picture picture
all right pull your guns right away face
oh
look out perfect i think we go east east
it is do you ever just
get a thing where like we were fine and
we started recording this and now
out of nowhere my nose is the itchiest
part of my body that's ever when i
didn't yeah dude my stream what is this
my nose always gets itchy my nose is so
itchy right now it hurts it hurts i
guess i don't know what you guys are
talking about
you need some distractions from your
itchy nose maybe a podcast called
distractionable or something maybe
distract double maybe a podcast called
impressionable uh and now that would be
a problem
are you guys hearing like a hissy oh
it's the bone yeah it's the bones i see
uh wait what do we shoot it it's done
great i like the way my arms shimmy it
looks really silly like a oh oh
production or something
take a picture of those rocks
all right
quick quick quick they're going they're
going they're going got it good good
good
yeah hate it when rocks just realized
we see insights oh more rocks got it
live action photo
live action brothers live photos i love
to take these bullets ooh bullets
hey i got a cleaver clue guys i found a
footprint fire works are you clueing so
hard right now oh my god fireworks
wow
that's a lot
of fireworks that has a lot of fireworks
well now the fireworks disappeared that
really seems like a one-time use sort of
thing
yeah you usually are
moose
yeah yeah that was a good shot we got
evidence of your murder
i'm sorry did we just set off other
fireworks what's happening what is that
was that fireworks falling back to the
ground and then exploding on the ground
i don't think so maybe some of them were
like i was just being fireworks like
right here weird this moose don't look
so good hey can you get a pick of me in
this moose i was here too i was here too
all right let me get enough we got
lincoln oh i have my knife let me get my
gun out i like mark's like 1000 yard
stare of his character he looks like he
really regrets the kill he's just better
and bob you have this shocked expression
like my boy killed a moose hey catch me
uh butchering it catch me butchering it
yeah beautiful oh i got you clean let me
get you with the bones there beautiful
how about that yeah pretty good rent
they get really dark
i don't know it's night time now
somebody flipped the switch
oh
oh the fence this is i found the fence
guys mmm nice fence
good nice
is that good yeah we survived oh look
it's
alice
[Music]
try that again
uh it's figaboot's favorite star rory
rory's bori
guys the ski lift where
oh you guys are very far from me yeah i
used my legs
beep beep beep what the hell oh motion
sensor on the camera over there does
anybody have the tablet see if i can get
it bob's controlling it right now so i'm
seeing bob move it around oh are you
watching this yeah oh god yeah i sure am
whoa sorry all right that was an
accident sorry
i didn't see anything i was too busy
trying to make wade motion sick dear
i didn't hear the associated
pig
oh god geez i kind of alert you before i
do it each time i know but you didn't
shoot the deer time but you shot it dude
yeah i shot the deer
oh i didn't hear the shot that time
shot silently yeah sneaky shot yes i
found a campsite with a box truck parked
at it that's good
empty cooler shotgun shells there yeah
bob do you want to get a shotgun
eventually
yeah come on buff you want to get a
shotgun do you want a maybe shotgun at
some point here you go you know you can
take the ammo
well he's got a sign
wow oh god his photo he didn't like it
oh he's mad
oh god he's real mad
oh yeah
oh [ __ ]
oh oh he spared me
his healthy guys i'm taking him i'm
taking him guys i'm taking it
oh
oh god he mad
i gave one of y'all's the flare
i don't have a flare did you give me a
player
yeah get out of here that's what we
thought i used up all my ammo and i'm at
half health did you use the gps thing
did you get the gps
though yeah who needs a med kid who
needs med kit
hang on wait
how did you shoot through him i don't
know there he goes he's running get out
of here that's what we thought i'm going
to set a trap you're running you're not
running i'm gonna set a trap that's a
good idea watch out trap there
i'm putting meat on it
i set one here you want to beat this
trap too yeah yeah yeah yeah you got it
all right stay inside the circle of
traps okay who needs first aid who needs
first aid i i first dated
i have half health
get him on the show
what in the hell i just fell over you
stepped out of this crap
no i got absolutely mauled to death oh
my god get him on track trap
trap crap trap truck
he trip very aggressive yeah take that
take that take that
oh another trap would be lovely
yeah do we have any more traps
oh boy yeah let me uh flare gun him i'm
out of flare gun
i don't have any ammo
he's on the trip he ignored the trap
ow oh god okay he's going he's got do we
how do we reset the traps pick it up all
this bro they're broken they're both
broken oh they're oh okay
maybe we flee now yeah we flee we flee
green to the west to the where where
where we're west yeah
if we just hide in the camper you can't
hurt us probably right probably yeah
that sounds about right it sounds like a
plan to me
i like to dick my wounds a bit so that
sounds different
what a damn that's expression whenever
you have like a wound you dick your
wound
i don't dick my wounds uh the camera is
going off right by the camper that's
good right hey
we're hanging out
pit stop these roads seem to congregate
big house oh multiple big houses big
campsite lots of goodies probably here
coming okay
yeah this looks good i bet there's
something sticking my wounds but not
coming
okay don't come i'm close
well i mean come but wait i feel like we
went the wrong way i gotta be honest
yeah i think we did too but if you're
close and i guess we might as well come
almost dude i'm close i'm here actually
do you feel smart we're here i've won
guys he's here get in get in the
building get it in bill i'm going
upstairs in this one wait okay you
wouldn't come in here right ah that's
the wrong button why is there an alarm
going that's
that door is blocked in it's okay guys
it's okay
a nine mil ammo i think it's for your
pistol bob i'll give that to you
whenever we meet back it is did you were
just gonna be quiet did you or did you
not get the gps thing
i don't have it anymore and i attacked
him
bullet for you oh sweet oh but how we
used it i don't know how do we track him
with it i don't know man oh
good yes and
or did the grandfather clock get really
loud for you all too no
no not the clack
okay
uh i'm in the house and this grandfather
clock just ding-donged right in
[ __ ] beware the grandfather
clack alexa i'm sorry i left and didn't
tell you i followed bigfoot's tracks
i found another they were talking to
like an actual like
alexa
i'm real sorry so are we like winning at
this sir
whoa uh he's got less health than he did
yeah how do we get more traps i feel
like we need traps yeah i haven't found
one i picked up one new one i think yeah
this place wouldn't actually be bad to
make a stand we could like run him
around quite a bit here i think or at
least place a series of traps like
upstairs if we do find him like upper
stairs leading to the upper floor of
this bigger building
huh we just need to go find him if we
could get some traps do we have any uh i
haven't won i have a zero i'm gonna go
run around and see if i can find in the
nearby another like camp bigfoot bigfoot
is here bigfoot is here where we where
are we piling he's southeast of us he's
running around okay
coming to us
he was coming over towards where you
were when you were on your own and then
he turned and ran away to the southeast
okay southeast okay oh like the way i'm
looking he ran that way do you wanna go
upstairs
yet he's not coming to us at night he
will i guarantee but uh while we still
have some time i'm gonna run down real
quick if i get killed i have enough
health and a first aid kit i should be
okay i am just exploring yeah i'm
exploring south west ish we'll meet back
up at that place i think that's our best
bet
okay
found stonehenge i don't know why
oh there's a mystical rune in here and
probably some magic [ __ ] going on i
got another gps sensor and some more
shotgun ammos very helpful i have
nothing to defend myself
bob be careful then this will be fine
oh god where's [ __ ]
where is that
that might be not by me i think wade i
think that was
pretty close to me yep
okay uh good luck i'm heading your way
bud
i don't know how much help i'm gonna be
but anybody got him on gps no i don't
even know how we see that
i have no idea either
oh there was a computer back at the i'll
run to the camera and see if i see him
on the computer maybe maybe oh maybe
what
oh my god you okay
oh yeah there's apparently apparently
bigfoot can set traps
what what
i just got slung up into a tree i'm
coming okay i got myself out yeah i i
was just walking along the road and then
i stepped apparently in a rope hole that
pulled me up into a tree trap good i
guess i'm going to try and get back to
the camper where weight is
oh what is all the grandfather clock
oh
jesus
oh you feel my pain
nice oh
um i'm coming to the camper don't worry
okay but that means he's not where i am
so i'm okay you all right
oh i've never felt worse all right well
use your flare next time yeah i just you
know i was looking at the computer and
then the window broke and there was a
hand grabbing me by the dick i see that
was your problem oh it's real quiet out
here
you having fun mark yeah i'm good man
just enjoying the peacefulness of the
night
got another trap in the meat are you the
trapper am i the truth trapping
oh oh
wait
what dad wait oh my god we're not safe
in here at all
again uh
go to the campsite it's probably safer
on the second floor it's not
we're stuck we're down mark oh my god
both of you are down i have 10 health i
don't know what i'm down or something
i'm down here i have nine health okay oh
god i i can't make it there in time i'm
coming but if he's oh oh my god that's a
bear that's not bigfoot it's a bit like
being mauled to death by a beast
what is he doing right now why this
bigfoot is such a dick oh my god it's a
freaking baby
it's i'm being attacked by a bear i'm
going to die
from this bear
it's not even bigfoot that's a problem
it's a freaking
bear oh bigfoot's a problem i'm coming
i believe in you buddy it's just
peek-a-boo in these windows man i found
a uh
oh i'm a bob i'm hoping it's not it
doesn't i have five health i'm doing
good on guys
i had a bear issue okay about to go to
five yeah mark you're eating really far
away damn what am i supposed to do
i don't know man oh hey you found a
building nice marker thanks okay got
that i got a new flare i'll bring it to
the beach [ __ ] right off
he's not leaving
ah wade roger that dying confirmed
oh
oh there you go
okay where is he yeah
the camper
oh
oh thanks
god he really just doesn't give a [ __ ]
about these flares does he
doesn't oh
oh oh god
oh now he goes all right well he ran
away all right
revive us okay cool
on the way my dudes
thanks bud and i'm here wow
how's it going
hey that's me i don't know what you're
that's my corpse thank you very much
[Music]
no i can't take that i hope he comes
back and smacks the [ __ ] out of you
you'll see i'll take it hey look he's
coming back
attack combo on you where did he go hey
i'm still standing yeah i know just keep
looting that's fine
what's the worst that could happen
oh hey mark he's coming back no no he's
not coming back
i think i might actually be able to
resurrect you guys if i'm not mistaken
oh do i have to like bring your body oh
oh no that sounds right actually yeah i
think yeah it does sound kind of
familiar yeah oh my god can i carry both
of you
he's the medic
please just file our court oh my god you
carry him like a baby uh i can only get
but oh i'm so slow there's no way
don't worry about that i don't cry
cradle me so delicately mark god i've
got you
oh no
no ignore that sound that's not a
problem box of cheez-its and have a
snack while uh waiting for my
resurrection you look absolutely
terrified i gotta say don't worry it's
gonna be fine i look pretty pissed i was
pretty unhappy anyway you want to
tell me a story
once upon a time
there was a brave young man
let's call him
flark
[Music]
needed to rescue his his friends who
were morons
and flarks
bravery knew no bounds he was brave
beyond all reason
almost insane you could say how brave he
was
embarked upon a journey
to rescue his first friend
by walking
awkwardly
for a long time
luckily flark's biceps and shoulders are
literally
the strongest thing in the universe
he's able to carry
say a dead body out in front of him like
it's a dirty diaper wow doesn't want it
to touch anything but needs to carry it
very carefully so as not to spill any of
the poopies
and or
dead bodies hearts
well
cool clark's quest seems to be going to
a rather successful end unless he's an
idiot too and doesn't know how this
works how do i drop you
hey like equip something else just like
hit like an oh there we go oh don't pull
your gun at me
so
there's i had totems right
and i got i grabbed one i can use this
totem to revive your friend at stone
edge okay how do i do that use the totem
uh i can't exactly put the totem in my
equip it can't you can okay where are
your on your wheels it should be in one
of the thingies it's like bottom left
you might just scroll wheel over one
thing
okay
uh do i put it on the skull thing
maybe okay maybe that seems like it's
something bob you feel more alive oh
something's happening
whoa
one totem short oh come on
do i have to get four
oh i have to get
that's unfortunate okay i'll be back
oh was the bravest of them all but boy
was he stupid
all right don't worry i'll uh a wade can
you go scout me a totem
i can only view you
right now
you sure haven't found one yet
you're not here a totem yet mark i can
tell you i can confirm
wade scouting you can kind of hear the
whisperies can't you i mean we did when
we got close to the one yeah
i already searched these days oh you
didn't okay all right that's all good
man four totems for one rez do you need
four more to res another person i'm
willing to bet yes oh boy well i don't
think they accounted for both of the
other players to be in the rv of death
it seems safe
we learned real quick the rv is not the
place to be there is not a single safe
place to be in that rv oh god there's
nothing here
cool well uh how does the how does the
story of flark end
uh
found a totem
and ran expeditiously back to stonehenge
rather proud of himself
i'm proud of ignoring the fact that he
had completely [ __ ] up the first time
and giving himself credit for doing it
right even though it took more than one
try
moral could be never give up on your
friends that you're trying to resurrect
uh flark never did give up
he ran jauntily back to stonehenge not
moving his arms at all tall
[Music]
too much muscle door open of the rv and
i'm pretty sure there's a raccoon
chewing on my ankle all right
all right clark paid no mind to whatever
friend he may have forgotten
nobody asked for a checking on the glade
all right well i'll just keep here
guarding the uh rv
with my rotting body and i am willing to
bet that the moment the skull goes down
some sort of magic yes you should
definitely flark should definitely stand
in that circle
[Applause]
hey yeah look at that here let me know
all these poles are gone here take why
don't you take this give that a give
this a wubb i am all right so wade
we just gotta find
four words
oh [ __ ] oh god and just in time glade
we're gonna be we're fine we're good
we're good we're fine it's fine
heard a
he's just yelling don't worry i'm gonna
trap him up glade believe in us give us
your power from the beyond
uh
there you go i feel powerful uh so how
do we attract him over here
uh
do you want to do that
yeah i don't know maybe we should focus
on saving glade is that a car bed let's
carb i don't know what to do with a car
battery but
hook it up to his nipples see if he
likes it maybe i shoot it when he goes
over it or something i'm gonna go get
the corpse okay go get the crew i mean
our friend yeah i guess i could look for
totems or something is there even more
totems
i don't know it's getting very dark oh
good well i've learned that being in the
rv in the night time when the yeti comes
is really a great place guys you die
in the rv again i'm so mad
well at least once you get my body it's
a quick run back yeah i know i'm just
gonna run the corpse in the evening time
over to the safety of stonehenge
mark i feel unsafe i have to be honest
you probably are should i go look for
totems
is stonehenge where you are on the map
where i am wow you're really mangled
yeah the raccoons did some work after
bigfoot and then a wolf came in and then
a deer came in and just kind of shat on
me all right i had a bad time i left the
trap there with the meat so i'm hoping
that he's going to go for that and not
us that sounds like it'll work it'll
definitely be a reasonable belief and
then i'm going to go hunt for more uh
totems all right we just need four
totems i've found none well i've got
none also hey i found a cabin though up
here did you take the one off of me
yeah i didn't think mark did yeah all
right what if there's exactly four
totems and you just locked into the only
four that exist
well then you're not going to come back
to life i don't know why you're saying
it menacingly to me
oh i'm stuck on a tree oh boy there's a
trap somewhere around there be careful
i'm not near the trap at all that would
be really helpful um
i missed the trap
oh
you're so fast he is he's fair oh bob he
knocked you down yeah he did though oh
shoot hey mark yeah what oh no
um
oh
oh guys
how many totems do you have
i think we're gonna need about eight
you're gonna land in total potentially
guys just just guessing spitballing you
know all right okay good let me uh let
me think about it you know let me
contemplate uh
contemplate okay let me calculate
tabulate a
things extra loot man it made a lot
we
few
easier to beat big
i was trying to jump off a mountain i
went on a yeah were you just trying to
jump off and kill yourself and you just
went on a super fun looking zipline
[Music]
oh hey right between the eyes find the
dick shoot him in the nips he'll never
get me oh he's got me
come here you why does he not want to
kill me and only ever kill you guys kill
me oh hey there he is
take this and that's that does four
damage per hit out of his like 13 100
health excellent come back and kill me
you coward
five damage per hit
you count
what are we supposed to do to deal 1300
damage to him well the trap did a lot of
damage but he destroyed the traps the
one time he stepped in it and you like
shoot him in the head or something he
come back here
the monster toyed with flock knowing
that all he wanted was to be put out of
his misery and refusing to give him the
only thing he truly desired
flark shot his stupid gun fruitlessly at
the monster repeatedly i think loading
more shells and firing them
knowing in his heart of hearts the
absolute and utter futility of his
actions what i don't understand is how
did you guys die
i don't know man he killed us in like
two punches
oh he got me clark stepped into a spiky
tree trap uh this is what i i'm still
his alive sustained him clark was nigh
unkillable
and an asset here to fourth considered a
good thing by most humans
but in florida's quest to end his
suffering
his unkillable nature was really most
frustrating
he almost could feel himself healing as
he wandered aimlessly through the woods
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go got it guys
mine said repeatedly please
end this go come on
troll
said
not today
all right
all right
take a nap for a while there am i not
yeah now you really have to bleed out
well someone's probably going to save
you that's what happened to me so
god
how are you doing down there margaret i
don't know man i don't know i think i'm
dying
oh boy oh maybe he'll come finish you
off like he did us what if he just
experienced taunted flock
knowing he couldn't even move maybe
he'll raise you as his own maybe
daddy bigfoot
how are babies made
he's not even out yet at this point
no not even remotely
then i guess people just have to listen
to distractible to get that joke have
you heard of the ship of theseus
flark's dying thoughts wandered as they
often did to the ship of theseus
was he even still flark
how do you decide who a person is
maybe he was just a stranger he never
met dying alone in the
woods maybe you should listen to
distractible
maybe i'll bleed out eventually
how much health you got
oh thank god
we got plenty yeah we can wait for this
i've been waiting all day to watch this
i just don't get
how did you guys die he did so much
damage to us i don't know
man
we were in that camper and he just
[ __ ] us up as [ __ ] sank into the
why is it me
what it's me
oh it's your own character i i see that
makes sense and he was really picking at
the end trails there
it took me a long time to get eaten out
in this game but at least i got there it
says that bigfoot survived come on so
178 damage 16 bullets two med kits for
me 55 damage 30 bullets one med kit for
you but you had to use a pistol bob
mark did 256 boards with five med kits
wow that's how you lived [ __ ] yeah
maybe that's why we died well i mean i
still had two med kits left so i i only
saw one med kit the whole game i offered
them to you but you i know you offered
buddy we realized you had a thousand med
kids
we learned a valuable lesson on this day
we suck
yeah
and flark were living in for me
you